[Music]
as a successful playwright for more than
10 years moira befini is a comparative
newcomer to cinema
but with two produced screenplays in the
last 18 months she's been making up for
lost time
the first a critically acclaimed
adaptation of posey simmons graphic
novel tamara drew was followed by a
version of the much film classic jane
eyre
for her third feature script moira
adapted one of her own stage plays
starring sausa ronan and gemma arterton
byzantium is a contemporary vampire tale
and further demonstrates that british
cinema has a powerful new female voice
[Music]
we're so behind the scenes we're sort of
hanging around on the edges of the set
in our anoraks
and
yet we're very much
part
of the process a vital vital part of the
process
the story is
is everything
[Music]
i think one of the reasons that writers
are kind of
slightly
sidelined is that is that we do our job
before the rest of it starts
we work
much more alone
than anyone else
concerned with the making of a film that
our part of the process comes first
and a writer's day is usually get up
make a cup of tea sit in a room and
write that's your day your day is spent
alone
two years ago pretty much to the week i
stepped onto a film set for the first
time in my life so please let me make
clear that these are not the wise
reflections of a screenwriting expert
these are the observations of a novice
nothing in a screenplay can be set in
stone although it needs to be as tough
as bricks
none of it can be precious
although it is highly prized
they are amazingly fluid malleable
documents and this is their strength
perhaps it's also their weakness where
the very plasticity of the screenplay
melts all over the set
screenplays have to be very strong very
robust very clear and very open to
change
and i think the same could be said of
the screenwriter
i think that she's got ideas and
ambitious ideas and that's exciting and
um and she takes that ambition to
adaptations obviously tamara true or
jane eyre you know she's not frightened
of taking on the classics
so strong and she really believes
you know she loves the process she loves
actors she loves um directors and
um i think she's fascinated by film and
um
it's really nice to have somebody
who can listen to you on set
and make your
ideas come true in a way because she's
got the power to write it how do you get
into this sort of space where you can
sit down typewriter and go for it or i'm
i'm a working mother writer right yeah
uh kids school sit down right
um and then i write until either i pick
them up from school or or the child
minder um
has had enough i am always thinking
i'm always thinking so you know making
the pasta i'm always thinking
so my first time on set
was a beautiful september day in a
lovely dorset village the film was
tamara drew my first screenplay into
production but not the first one written
which i'll come to in a bit
stephen fries is rare in the way that he
works with and relies upon his writers
and i don't think his way of working
would suit everyone when he met me he
said you do realize i'm going to make
your life hell
and i thought
ah
this is where it begins this is where
all the stories that i've heard of
screenwriters being chewed up spat upon
abused and generally left lying face
down in hollywood swimming pools this is
where that life starts
over time mr freeze and i developed a
great way of working
a lot of script changes were made on set
often because you'd simply think of
better lines or realize when they
weren't necessary i stress tested scenes
before they were shot rewriting
specifically for the actors sometimes
with the actors getting them to read
scenes out for me to try and make it
better all the time
sometimes i agreed with stephen and
sometimes i disagreed he liked scenes i
tossed off in minutes he hated scenes
i'd agonized over for days
and sometimes he'd read something i'd
written and simply say
i don't know how to shoot that
which was a really good lesson
it's undoubtedly a better screenplay for
all the work that i did during its
making i was involved at every stage
from the casting to the final edit and
what a brilliant education it was
you know haddon's always packed with
piss lumber nights on a friday i don't
we get a table anyway let's do it
properly next week make an occasion i'm
always taking you for granted i'm vile i
know you should kick me really
who is she
what
oh come on beth
tell me who
with the particular character of
tomorrow she's a real weird feminine
character so me and maura had this you
know we'd have we stayed in the same
hotel together and we would have dinner
together and discuss
look
it's nothing
it's been once or twice that's all it's
just beth it's not anything who is she
i've worked with writers though
no no no always do this always do that
you didn't do it the way i've written it
and it's so suffocating and moira loves
actors she's worked in theater a lot and
i think she understands the process um
and uh so she you know she's open to
that but at the same time you know she
she lets you bring the character alive
as well it's all written what what
changed in the filming was
the exactness of the writing the writing
has to be so exact
and and
stephen fries and the actors and i
went
visited the location
walked it all through and we blocked
exactly where each scene ending needed
to come where you would cut away to the
the the the table outside um exactly
where each lines would be spoken and
exactly what those lines would be what's
her name nadia nadia patel patel she's
in your book no no i met her when i was
on desert island put her in your book
well just the name that's thailand this
was a year ago yes so once or twice i
was going to tell you
in the book
i'm a ruin i know but i've been in a
real state about this i i didn't want to
hurt you oh
how could you lie to my face can we talk
calmly about this there are people out
there
i'm lying
at the top i kind of wrote around you
know scene nine our owl
what it became was it became 16 scenes
it became a row
into cut with an alfresco dinner
the row was caught was was filmed at one
location
then it was intercut with an alfresco
dinner which was filmed at another
location
um
and uh the 14 scenes were written
on location with stephen fries and the
actors and and we worked the row out
which had been written as a scene we
reworked it into
into
very very useful short scenes so that on
the night of the shooting where
everybody's up to here and under
pressure and it's cold outside and it's
really late
you're not thinking oh well actually
that isn't going to cut with that or
it's useful you're just being useful to
everybody else
i was paid for writing three screenplays
before tamara drew and jane eyre got
made
and there you go
films are hard to learn and even harder
to get made
one mistake i made was to write a story
in a genre i wasn't suited to which was
horror
i didn't know i wasn't suited to it
before i set out but alarm bells should
have been set ringing by the fact that
i've never willingly gone to see a
horror film
the screenplay i wrote went down okay
although it didn't get made and i got
lots of offers to write more
but horror made me unhappy
the genre requires horrible deaths and
that's how you spend your day while
you're writing alone with horrible
deaths
every genre has its rules
and my instinct has always been to
resist them plays don't have genres they
tend to defy genre or subvert it and at
first i took this attitude with me into
writing film
northern seoul my first unmade
screenplay was a ghost story not a
horror there is there is a difference
but it was well it wasn't really about
the ghost and it was warm in tone it was
working class family drama meets
poltergeist
meets carrie i heard someone say
the result although quite original was
probably
impossible to market
and this is the impossible lesson really
that the question no one's got the
answer to what's got the best chance of
getting made
when i heard on the grapevine that bbc
films and ruby films were wanting to
make
a screen adaptation of jane eyre
i knew i had to have the job
two reasons one i loved the book and two
i knew it would get made i just knew it
it's jane eyre there's an idea in in
late 20th century theater i think that
everything has to be about society it
has to be about the here and now it has
to be about real life
and
and film i i think is very good at not
being about real life now now you know
real life's all very well
but
i love the idea that something can both
be about real life and not be about real
life and and i think i slightly seek
that in both my plays and my films
i i mean i think the other thing that
really a that attracts me
um
are kind of legend stories greek myths
and and so on and so forth um it is it
is the
the scale of the story the way the way a
story can take on
um
the tiny and the personal
and the
and the relationship and
between the human being and the universe
some stories can do that they have
massive resonance and i and i think
those are the sort of stories
that that i've always looked for in the
theater and i'm beginning to look more
for in film although they always come
through little
little bunches of human beings being
very clumsy with one another i loved
charlotte bronte's language and i wanted
to honour it and yet i wanted the film
to be fresh and modern and for our times
i thought of jane eyre the self-taught
artist and i tried to see everything
through her artist's eyes
it became apparent while i was writing
the first draft that the structure of
the book wasn't going to work
i changed it from linear to circular
transforming it from an expansive novel
into an ever tightening film
there was less work to do on set there
was much less work to do on set and i
went up primarily for the pleasure of
watching
for the pleasure of watching the actors
at work
um and there were little minor things
that came up
um but but mostly the script was filmed
as written
you can't improvise bronte i mean it's
bronte
[Music]
i felt slightly in the way
and i think this is the much more
regular experience of the screenwriter
on set
it was in the edit that i found myself
useful once again i love edits and
editors
i think they have a lot in common with
writers
they are
writing the film in in images all the
thousands of fragments
they're the writer who puts them back
together again
[Music]
the process of writing is difficult and
it can make writers difficult
we find it actually physically painful
sometimes and most painful when our work
is not treated well
it happened to me once that a play i was
writing was mistreated and i found
myself with constant heartburn
i was raw from head to toe
oh for god's sake i kept saying to
myself it's only a play get over it get
over it get over it walk away
and i did but this is what i learned
until a piece of work
is finished
it is still attached to the writer
viscerally
rochester talks of a string under his
heart
connecting him to jane eyre
and i think writers have similar strings
connecting them to their work
until it is finished
it is still partly inside us
and this is why it hurts
when it's
tugged out
but perhaps this pain of premature
separation
is what's kept me so far from attempting
the original screenplay so far i have
chosen to conceive
all my original ideas in the theater
because i know i'll have more artistic
control over them
it's as simple as that
i think it takes great courage
to develop an original screenplay and
and
give it over
before you really even know what it is
i i think
uh in the theater you're allowed
to stay close to the process for long
enough to really know what that story is
and to really shine and polish it and
get the best out of it um
and i have been i i freely admit i've
been too afraid in the film world to do
that yet
um i think also adaptations are easy
when you're working with so many
collaborators
the ad the the source material is
something upon which you are all agreed
when it's an original idea there is no
source material there is nobody's agreed
on anything it's so nebulous
and and
the the safety of developing the
original idea in the theater has so far
really appealed i'm sure that one day i
will develop the courage to step out
there and write the original screenplay
but it hasn't come to me yet
when you're writing an original idea
you have
you have something inarticulate inside
you
like like a big question mark
that the idea
through story
is attempt attempting to articulate
um usually when when i've got an idea
coming on it's just the idea is a
burning this sounds so
you know up itself it's i feel like
there's something just burning inside
that
and through the story you work it out
you work it out you think yes that's
that's what it is this is what this is
what i'm trying to articulate scenarios
are really really easy to think up
that they keep thinking up scenarios and
going oh god that's a good scenario
beginnings are really really easy to
think up the really really difficult
thing to think up
is
the ending is the solution is how does
it resolve
and that's what you're always looking
for as a project it's something that has
a really really satisfying resolution
and and that's when you know
you've got it that that it's going to
make a a really good film and b
be
possible
to write to the very best of your
ability and she's just written a
screenplay adapted from her own play
byzantine which is a holy original
vampire story
and you know her theater work you can
see her taking on big ideas
and i think that's what's exciting about
her as a writer sometimes by obeying the
rules of a genre you can be even more
fresh and original than when you're
trying to break them
byzanti and my screenplay currently in
pre-production is adapted from my play a
vampire story the premise of the play
are they or aren't they vampires
works really well on stage
in the theater there's no such thing as
a vampire genre the audience has no
expectations
and the ambiguity of not knowing what
these two girls were was really good fun
but the tone didn't translate each draft
kept eluding me
neil jordan came on board and said of
course they're vampires it's a vampire
film
stephen woolley had been saying this to
me all along and at last i took it on
board i embraced everything about it
and the story hasn't lost any of its
originality in fact it's
gained good vampire stories are always
about something other than vampires
they're about human beings seen through
a twisted prism
the genre sets the prism up that's all
this is byzantine this just happened to
be in my bag
so this is this is today's draft and by
next week it will have changed
um and uh we would we were just down
looking at locations this morning and
talking them through
and uh
i'm going to rework the
ending in light of some of the locations
that we were looking at because there
was a bit of dodgy
motivation going on why does this
character do this and we weren't coming
up with a very good answer
and and the
you know having the location has
actually inspired us
to that answer
it's rare for me to even have a printed
up script i never keep anything uh i'll
go through a note session scribble all
over it do the rewrites and then it's
gone it's it's into the recycling i
never keep
anything
um
so it's quite rare that i've got one of
these i want to write parts that are
delicious and not wearisome for
actresses to play
don't get me wrong i think men are very
interesting i love writing them
and if the story is good you never
notice the gender of the protagonist do
you if the story is good and the film's
well acted and well made you should be
lost in it you should be empathizing so
fully with the protagonist you should be
so anxious on their behalf and so
wrapped up in their life that you don't
notice until afterwards
how different their life and their
experience is from your own
i don't notice when i'm watching a
brilliant film about men
but i think we do notice more when we're
watching a brilliant film about women
because there are far fewer of them i
think there's fertile ground out there
for putting a woman's life at the heart
of a film and not just rom-coms and
horrors
she's very young moira and she's she's
street wise and she's real she's very
cultured she's always out of theater she
was you know
i think that really you see that in her
work she's not shut away you know like
slaving over the laptop she she lives
and you really see that
like an actor she soaks up what's around
her and watches how people behave and
understands people
so that's why pieces are storied you
know character story driven rather than
action driven i write dramatically
because i'm fascinated by who we are and
what we do by our character our
clumsiness our ingenuity
our corruption
our capacity for love
our
temptations our excesses our endeavors
our cruelty our egotism our foolishness
our flaws
the comedy of us the tragedy of us the
beauty of us and the horror
the percentage of films released each
year that are written by women
is still tiny
and this is surprising to me because i
found it to be an amazing career i'm my
own boss
i'm very decently paid
i pretty much choose my own working
hours and by and large i can fit them
around my kids
but
i wonder what has put women off
embracing this career for so long i now
know we're entering it in much greater
numbers women filmmakers and film
writers are beginning to proliferate
but
why is it that we haven't done it so far
surely a career where you could be
sacked at any moment where you don't own
your own work or have any rights over it
where failure is public and brutal where
your status is low and where directors
are horrible bullies will steal all your
credit surely such a career would be
attractive to anyone
i mean we have a couple of women writers
coming through i mean there's such a
there's a great range but theater seems
to be a common denominator in terms of
voices and a training ground there are
so many more young women writing for
theater than there was when i when i
started writing for theater just 15 15
16 years ago i mean the theater the
theater is is a wonderful um
place
to find your own voice
more so than television i think where
writers start out writing largely series
tv where the very point is that you're
supposed to sound like all the other
writers that that's that's the necessity
of the of the job but in the theater you
are paid well not much but you're paid
for the originality of your ideas and um
i stayed in the theater for a very long
time i i've hardly written any telly i
mean virtually none i i went straight
from theater to film
and i'm very very glad that i stayed and
developed and
learnt
a bit more about my own voice behind the
camera in terms of the creative process
there's still more work to go in terms
of directors and writers i think it's
improved but still you know we have to
be vigilant um i think you see a lot
more women in tv tvs seems to be much
more of a female friendly medium now is
that because women tend to write certain
sorts of stories that seem to be more
domestic i don't know i'm only saying or
there's a perception that they're good
at those stories soap operas etc
i actually think that's kind of rather
sort of uh incorrect women can write
everything i've done about 15 films or
something and moya is the first female
writer
including television include you know
everything that i've done has been made
i don't i don't know why that is and
um
maybe it's even i read scripts they're
like girly rom-coms and they're all by
guys you know and it's very weird i
think there's a lot more work to be done
in terms of you know inspiring a
generation to say yes you could do this
and i think that's again why maura's
talk uh bafta was so fantastic it was
inspiring uh you felt there was a kind
of can do quality um and uh that's
really exciting
when i started out i read one of the
books i think everyone reads one of the
books um how to write a screenplay in so
many days with 101 tips to enhance
character
and in the books you're introduced to
the sterile language of structure
mr freeze refused to use any of this
language when you talk to him about
backstory he'd virtually snarl
i'm familiar with this script jargon but
i don't like it
character arc
moral wound
i find these terms reductive
and anti-creative
the books make you think that structure
is a science but in a science if you
follow a particular set of rules you'll
always get the same result
the disappointment must be great when
all those tips to enhance character and
a perfect three-act arc have still
created something lifeless
and cliched
structure's hard to learn
and i'm still learning you really have
to wrestle with it
but it begins to become second nature
the rules disappear under your skin and
become felt
you feel act changes you get attuned to
pace
and at the end of the day
structure is only the climbing frame on
which we can play
if it's solid
then we can take risks
distilled into the screenplay should be
everything the actors the production
designer the cinematographer and the
director and all the other team need to
make the film they're strange documents
hardly anybody reads them
maybe no more than one or two hundred
people
but the way in which they're read the
detail with which they're scrutinized is
unbelievably thorough
you have to try it you have to try to
see and feel every moment of the film
vividly
from the perspective of every character
and then you have to let it go because
your collaborators will see it
differently
you trust
always that they will see it better
i would never want to be tied down to a
particular genre or theme ever and i
would always choose
my next project to be as different as
possible from the last
it's funny whatever you write you get
offered a lot of work immediately
afterwards in the same genre like when
tamara drew cream out i got lots of lots
of comedies lots of english village kind
of uh lots of romantic comedies and with
jane eyre it has been classical novels
you know and i've and i i just gone a
different way entirely the next one's a
vampire film i mean you know i i would
always want to go a different way
she does have this tremendous ability to
write
differently for different people i mean
having seen jane eyre
which obviously is an adaptation again
and then having read byzantine the
script i'm doing with her you can't say
that then we're a bifini script they
don't she doesn't have that kind of
identity like some writers do she's very
very flexible when the production of a
play is over all that remains is the
script the script is the lasting thing
[Music]
when a film production is over
the script
has vanished
that document has gone it's invisible it
has disappeared into the fabric of the
images
it's holding them up
but what remains
is what you see
so
i'm at the beginning of something and
i'm trying to eke this beginning out for
as long as i can because this job is
full of possibilities
talk to me in 10 years time and you
might find me chewed up battered slapped
and jaded
time will tell
but bring it on i say bring it on
[Music]
[Music]
you